talking about because I was responding
to the other one I just said okay if you
don't clean you don't cook and you don't
know with him what does he get out of
that
and that's
half
yeah
okay if you could start if you get fat
oh God you're not loyal because you know
70 to 80 percent of women in the U.S are
overweight 70 80 yeah so yeah so so
that's one two we're not loyal we leave
70 to 80 percent of the time
on top of that
um one out of four marriages is sexless
so and I I can't imagine most women
really have their original recipes
really cater to men support them so it's
like it's like we really say we're doing
a good job as a group I'm including
myself in this right but it's saying as
a group can we say we're we're offering
a lot
I feel like a lot of it comes down to
the fact that marriage is now
a nearly a political statement is
nothing to do with the religion aspect
of it I'm not religious myself but I
come from a very religious background
I'm born and raised in Northern Ireland
very religious and all the basis of
marriage is like the core elements of it
you take religion out of that yeah
marriage kind of is nothing but a
statement yeah she's right she's no
you're right because it's the because
religion has become you know morted down
and fewer people are religion religious
today and also societal constraints but
the societal constraints came out of
religion didn't they you know the whole
reason that it was so
um frowned upon for people to be
divorced and certainly for women to be
divorced in the past was because of the
religious aspects to it we'll take out
the religion and suddenly it's like well
what is the incentive do you know what I
mean there is no incentive and that's
that's the problem with the marriage
contract now
I think that's quite sad because I feel
like marriage has lost its meaning like
let's not forget marriage is a beautiful
thing it's a sacred thing but that's
only that's only if you're religious
that's the issue that that is coming up
at the minute I think they come at that
no but the marriage
I answer I'm saying
don't actually get that security the
type of security that you get when
you're married doesn't get sick because
the man doesn't get the security because
70 of the women leave I would say yes
it's we don't get security okay we
wanted to work we said send us to work
and then we go to work and now the wages
are cut in half for everyone when you
got double the amount of employees it's
our own fault and then women women who's
in charge of sex right so women said you
know what I used to require marriage to
have sex with me now we don't do that so
spots our own fault broke down because
of women
[Music]
I'll tell you I'll tell you this my
grandma my grandma
old lady sweet lady she had nine kids my
dad had 13. my mom had I got a lot big
family right and you know she's getting
older right and I asked her
um like Grandma why do you think like
the divorce rate spiked so much because
the divorce rate really went um up in
the 60s right and I was like Grandma
like what like why is that like what
what happened you were you around right
she looks at me she says birth control
made him do it
oh okay
there's enough stats but if you look if
you look birth control rate and the
divorce rate they're the same
so what are you saying that the birth
control does something to the women kind
of thing no I think women just wanted to
sleep around oh yeah lovely I mean
Barbie world has shown to have a
difference in your
yeah because I've had attractiveness
basically it's just what you're
attracted to at the time when you're a
hormonal yeah I heard that I've heard
stories there's some really interesting
research I'm very scientific I I study
science as a degree some really
interesting research on it but it still
doesn't give to a reason have you heard
about women who get married to a dude
when they're on birth control and they
come off
that's not a materialistic thing though
at least at least it's just it's it's
something a bit deeper there isn't it do
you know why that is that because when
she's on the birth control she's looking
forward yeah dude it's a completely
different hormonal imbalance in the body
so when you come off the breast control
is it different hormones is it basically
when she's on birth control she's
looking for a more of a dad kind of
character and then she comes off it
she's looking forward I think it's a
personal preference
you're right because I thought it was
because this isn't when you're on birth
control like the body tricks you into
and you're looking for those aspects
like a strong man man with good
selective genes good eggs I thought you
wanted the resources because you already
got you but that that's the you when you
feel that you're pregnant you want that
security but then when you come off it
it's just [__] go wild in it I mean
that's the issue though in it they come
off it and they're like yeah
they want they're more they're more up
for yeah yeah any anything because
there's an idea there's I don't know if
you guys agree with this or not but
there's an idea in the men's online you
know advice space that basically women
look for two different things they look
for the dads and they look for the cats
so they look for the guys who are more
like the provider guys more he's a nice
guy he's Dependable he's solid he's got
a good pension pension planning place
and all that stuff and then you've got
the sexy the sexy dude over here who
maybe hasn't got any of that stuff but
he's ripped and he's like Devil May care
and he's like he does you know he's that
kind of and and there's this idea that
women look for those two things so what
it sounds like you're saying is that on
the birth control they go for the first
and then they come to birth control
they're like right where's Chad yeah
where's the pool boy anything these days
men wants kids more than woman wants
kids I think it's I um
I think today's society though is not
more about what the man or woman wants
it's more about what's being pushed on
you yeah so a lot of people are thinking
I don't want too many children because
the financial aspect of it or I don't
want too many children because the
environmental aspects of it or it's just
personal preference
yeah exactly and there's a huge amount
of evidence now saying if you're into
your 40s and you're having a child you
increase the risk of them having severe
other problems abnormalities having Down
syndrome and as much as those children
they thrive in life but it's not fair to
push that on them knowing you're you're
going into your 40s and you're having a
child I mean I I don't I don't agree
with it it's not fair when she was 45
not it's not everyone it's not everyone
but the science the science supports it
saying once you reach a certain point
you increase that risk of something like
that happening or still births or having
a child that has fear fatal fatal and
which then into their very very young
years end up dying so I think that's a
lot of the things that now because we
have the research back and up people are
going well it's too late and I don't
wanna I don't want to force that on a
child which is fair which is fair with
both sides man and woman I think it's
both works both ways what age is it over
for a woman
what age is it like it's you're not
gonna be a wife well it's really but it
depends about kids let's talk about okay
let me I'm just going to clarify a
little bit we're not going to talk about
the exceptions I know somebody yeah
there's always going to be acceptable
all right there's always going to be so
I heard a lady gave birth at 60. oh yeah
but nothing knowing knowing that men
today are more hesitant to get married
right and half of they're predicting
half of women in our age group aren't
even going to be married they're you
know 50 of us in the room never married
no kids that's what they're predicting
okay at what age
is it would you say over you know
probably No One's Gonna Marry You no
one's if no one's trying if no one's
tribed if no one's tried to marry you
yet you're probably never gonna get it
oh what age what do you think
um as a woman
um what age would you say when you're a
spinster like no offense like for late
late 40s 45 late over okay kind of yeah
when do you think it's over oh yeah I'd
say probably 45 and over yes okay 45
same yeah 40. I'm gonna come back to you
45.
I think because a lot of people because
people who are getting married tend to
want families doesn't it so they're
going to look at them and go what if I
might love you but I yeah but in
traditional aspects marriages to support
a family and they might look at it and
go we're most likely not going to have a
child so I mean if I'm not religious is
there any point get married at this
point that's why I said I didn't say
relationship no marriage all right Trey
what do you think what age uh 27. 27. oh
my God
I knew that would trigger that I knew
that would trigger everyone I just like
the precisis specific
um in all seriously so if we're talking
about having kids though as well like
not just are we talking marriage and
kids this is just personally I feel like
most guys over a certain age still get
in a long-term relationship with a girl
but why get married if there's no kids
yeah no true true so true at what age is
it would you say as a guy you're like um
couldn't start a family with her you can
have to be but if you don't have kids so
if she if you had a girl you really
liked right and you were thinking of
someone you wanted to start a family
with but you said you know what too old
I mean to be honest I think it's going
to be like mid-30s yeah yeah
realistically because of the things
you're talking about as well because you
start to think getting much older than
that you start thinking well you know
would everything be be okay you know
um
yeah
because if you think about it what do
women's Peak fertility use really yeah
it's like 22 23 right yeah yeah yeah
just under 25 I think yeah you start
reaching 30 that's when it starts we're
getting quite dangerous yeah 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30. yeah wow crazy
that's why marriage used to be so much
younger that's why people used to get
married a lot younger but now now a lot
of people don't want to have children so
they get married a lot later because
it's yeah I mean you could definitely if
it's just if it's just marriage for like
companionship then to be fair people
could get married older you know like
you might meet somebody you know in the
nursing home and you're just like all
right on the death bed oh my God I need
to spend this money
I noticed are you engaged I saw the I
see that me no I always get asked this
no this is um on the right hand not on
the left hand okay no everyone always
asks me that no not yet soon maybe
hopefully hopefully we pray
um okay next question next question
because I feel like I was given so much
Flack for this are you a good wife if
you get married and then you gain 100
pounds is that good wife
I'm just I'm just asking am I off base I
mean was there a reason for that like
it's so impossible it doesn't matter the
reason I mean you're not a bad wife for
gaining a hundred pounds
so like okay let me let me just say so I
lost my job and refused to work as a
husband but I did it for a reason
am I a good husband
you know I lost my job but I was
depressed I mean I think that happened
it could be on benefits yeah I didn't
say I didn't say that it doesn't happen
I didn't say you couldn't work through
it I just said good good means like a
student good A B student right that's
good um I don't know I kind of need
specifics because like gaining weight
and being depressed
obviously you could gain weight as a
girl because you're depressed
so so you know I got married I'm in love
I'm just gonna just get a Krispy creams
every day if if you're not willing to
look out for your own health though yeah
yeah
no I don't I don't think it is so my
question good wife or bad wife
see I don't think it's I don't think
it's quite a straightforward but in it
I have a question you have to pick one
you gotta pick good or bad I have a
question I I would say if I'm still
looking after him and doing all the
things that a wife should do but yeah I
just gained a few pounds or whatever I
said 100. yeah what still looking after
him he can't say nothing I'm still a
good wife
all right I'm gonna get the same person
like does it change does it look at
Piers Brosnan is that his name is that
his wife the old James Bond his wife was
stunning when they were young and now if
you look at her she's gained a lot of
weight and he told them he was like I
didn't fall in love with her because of
the way she looked he was like I fell in
love with her soul yeah yeah I think
that sounds like I don't know why men
cap he would not have approached her
come on like
they sell us this fairy tale you know
I'm not saying that she can't provide
other things but that action all right
can we just sorry that action is that a
good wife
I didn't talk about her cooking
as well like if you don't care and
there's no backline issue to why you've
done that no it's a bad way yeah it's a
because if you don't care and you've
gone you should love me the way I am if
that's how it was in the beginning then
that's why maybe I'm coming across a bit
strong did you say she was oh she was
real who said they're real she's the
realest so far
okay okay next one on my list all right
if you refuse to have sex with your
husband good wife or bad wife bad okay
thank you thank you good night for bad
refused yeah I'm gonna say I need
contacts yeah like I have no idea what
that means I think in a stereotypical
sense because normally when a woman
refuses is because there's an emotional
disconnect or there's something that's
seriously going wrong then should you
still use should you still be married
then or should you got married and
satisfied no but I mean
I have a question do good wives put
their feelings above what's best for the
family
yeah oh it's me well I don't I don't
feel right so let me just not sleep with
my husband because of the way I feel is
that a good wife my feelings before
everybody else's I mean as long as
you've expressed that to your partner
and he's okay with that no I don't have
to be open I just wanna I just don't
have a question I'm just just yes
are you guys okay
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible